in honor of mother's day this sunday
we're taking a look at a growing trend
in motherhood women becoming single moms
by choice advancements in fertility
treatments and the expansion of medical
insurance coverage have made it possible
for more women to have children on their
own one of our very own cbs morning
producers did just that i spoke with her
and others about creating a family with
only mom at the helm
i had an aching to be a mother i had a
longing to be a mother at 40 years old
cbs news producer wendy mcneal gave
birth to her daughter harlow
a lifelong dream so important to her
that she chose to have the baby on her
own i said to myself in 15 to 20 years
would i be
more upset that i didn't have a kid or
more upset that i didn't fall in love
and get married and i was like if i
didn't have a kid for me i feel like my
life wouldn't be as fulfilled
she picked a donor and went through
three rounds of fertility treatments
holding harlow in her arms is a reminder
she made the right choice even when
she's like
[Music]
[Laughter]
even when she's like this
and gets a little fussy
[Music]
i'm grateful that like she made me a
mother and that like i got this
opportunity
40 years ago when new york
psychotherapist jane mattis became
pregnant fewer women were purposely
having children on their own i was 36
and
all my friends were actually having
fertility problems and it occurred to me
that i might not have this opportunity
again i was one of these people who was
told a lot you'll be such a wonderful
mother so she decided to have the baby
knowing his father would not be in the
picture to get the support she needed
she created her own village and started
single mothers by choice you really
can't raise a child alone but you can
make sure that
as a single parent you have a lot of
people in the child's life who love that
child over the years that network has
connected 30 thousand women mattis
attributes the growth to better
fertility treatments more inclusive
medical insurance a change in societal
attitudes and higher incomes for women
as for mattis's son he started his own
family making his mother a grandmother
my genes were chosen brothers mackenzie
and cooper schoenthaler were chosen by
their mother a doctor more than two
decades ago she had them at 41 and 45
using the same donor do you miss not
knowing who your father is
frankly no you know we have an amazing
family and amazing family relationships
we loved our childhood like we have a
very caring mother and see our parents
cry you know and and scream and throw
things and because there weren't two
parents how has that impacted your own
relationships by not seeing tension by
not seeing people work through those
same things that you spoke of i think
that
i am more conflict avoidant than other
people as a result because i was raised
in a household with zero conflict
perhaps that's one of the drawbacks the
brothers have few demographic details
about the man who contributed to their
dna but they do have his extensive
medical history what would you ask him
i mean i would thank him for giving away
sperm because i know
that can be sort of just an odd thing
for someone to do especially knowing
that they have potentially 10 or more
kids running around the world but i
would also thank him for being tall
we're definitely appreciative of being
taller than the rest of our family he's
given us
nothing but genetics and that's crucial
yay for baby harlow she can decide if
she wants to know who her donor is when
she turns 18.
i know until then mcneal is prepared to
tell her daughter how she got here i'm
always going to be open and honest and
transparent you know she doesn't have a
dad she has a donor i had her on my own
she never closed the door on finding
love just open the one that led her to
baby harlow
first so now you can still do that but
you have fulfilled
the dream the want the desire
to be a mom yeah and i can do it on my
own terms
we are now joined
by wendy mcneill and her beautiful baby
her first live television interview
four months arlo wendy thank you so much
hi friends for joining us and i tell you
you know when i saw you a few months ago
more than a few but
um you told me you know that you were
making this decision and i thought we
should do a story yeah because i've
heard more and more women over the years
making that decision what was the
tipping point for you because you talk
about saying would i be more upset if i
didn't you know have a child but i did
go for trying to get married and whatnot
but what was that tipping point i i had
an aching a longing to be a mother
and for me that meant
doing it by any means necessary and i
had to get realistic about my
circumstances i mean the fact of the
matter is i was in my late 30s
and you know there are certainly
biological pressures that we face
and
you said it was like an article too that
you saw yeah and it felt like i i
basically was
like i had asked the universe i was like
give me a sign that this is the path
that i need to take and the sign the
sign came in the form of this op-ed in
the new york times it was called
um single at 38 have that baby
and i was like
done and i read the one i read the story
and the woman i completely related to
and i was like this is it i'm gonna do
it we know that insurance played a role
in this too i mean you have the coverage
so talk to us about that in terms of you
know women who are watching this or
thinking about that yeah i mean i'm
fortunate that i work for an employer
that you know provides reproductive
insurance and i was able to do this
basically almost nothing out of pocket
little to nothing out of pocket
and that's not you know something that
is extended to a lot of people it's a
blessing they are over making googly
eyes
i gotta get a smile because they got a
smile on me i know she got a smile
it's that fun age right now where like
she's showing a little bit of
personality and the smiles are coming
out and so it's a fun time how do you
deal with the tough parts because it is
just you i breathe through it
and i always find gratitude when i have
the moments where like it's a little
tough i will work through that and then
i'll come back to gratitude because
the fact that i'm even i was able to
have her
and
you know and it's been a pretty smooth
process at this point like i always come
back to gratitude and i know you know
this but here at cbs
she has a bunch of cousins uncles
aunties grandmothers grandfathers this
is family so you know we're all a phone
call away yes i love you guys so much
that i've already had so much support
from you guys i've had conversations
with each of you about parenting and
asking questions and
so thank you so much and for all your
support for we're here for you harlow we
got you girl
go lolo yeah lolo's for nikki
hello